[Music]
in carny drama news god yeah no
submitted by hungry potato yeah a makeup
artists complaint about quad eb from
almost a year ago as one has recently
gone viral
oh this was in my feed I didn't keep not
clicking on it but it keeps showing up
in my food the one is it the one where
the girl is like my worst client ever
cardi B is the title sorry not good yeah
that one yeah yeah that keeps showing up
on my feet I'm like I'm not interested
this is a thumbnail yeah that's the one
that's why you're in the news now take
it away from her just annoyed of cardi
sounds while she was applying makeup the
her name is mu a makeup artist Black
Swan and that's what she is there
another picture of her cuz she looks
kinda pretty sure her makeup is really
cool okay doesn't even look like she has
makeup on so she did a 36 minute long
video where she uploaded this back in
January no clue how now all of a sudden
it's relevant and now I got it went
viral no idea cuz the algorithm yeah
like no not these people that have been
building their YouTube forever please do
you want more of these sauce if I get
the monetize one more [ __ ] time I
swear to [ __ ] god what will you do
David
I will go to Facebook I will stay on
YouTube forever there you go I've been
posting videos on Facebook yeah
basically back home that's what I'll do
I'll start my own thing is car you know
I won't stop please don't he doesn't get
monitor Steve's didn't monetize and I
just don't get my fee completely be
monetized hi you Andy will let her like
I clicked notifications and you still
don't get notification my ship will be
like the best noodles in the world on an
inappropriate first that much in this
movie can you d
LS noodles [ __ ] [ __ ] come on man all
right so this video so this story time
video has 4.6 million views when I first
saw it in my feet I had 600,000 Wow
that's actually going viral yeah
normally I hear something went viral one
I'm like yeah huh okay 30,000 clicks on
I'm not gonna start doing all fake vlogs
about celebrities and just talk about my
worst experience with them like the way
[ __ ] Johnny Depp try to [ __ ] mouth
kiss me dude Nikki do you had a bunch of
experiences with celebrities cause
issues Dorcas yeah we just never come
out with those stories cuz that's like
I'm going to absolutely do that why
that's just slandering people for no
reason
yes I hate that she's getting black some
chicks she's not my business there
they're on their own they're celebrities
know people making us do YouTube we're
like slander yeah that's we're forced to
because that's what the algorithm favors
true you're forced to drama and slander
one another and start beefs with that's
what is getting rewarded penny - oh no
sinning - out now download now available
alright so this story let me tell you
guys the team so this makeup artist she
was saying that she had two experiences
it was hardly the first one was when
cardi went to Houston where she was and
she did her makeup and that cardi loved
it so much she took a photo of it this
is what the result was she was Cardini
Jesus Tabata that's core to be right
there she was like Dennis the Menace
dude she looks more like Nicki Minaj
hello Versace she look like a white girl
yeah she's like a white yeah so I don't
know I mean she said it was flawless and
that was really good she was like Cher
and Barbra Streisand put together
pretty weird so anyway so then the
makeup artist is saying that this next
time at cardi we went into town that she
specifically requested her because she
loved her makeup so much so then when
she gets there she says that she got
there right on time and that cardi was
on the phone and she was like all heated
I don't know she was in a bad mood
she made her weight about 40 minutes to
an hour before she could even do her
makeup and then finally when she went up
to go do her makeup that the whole time
kardea just kept talking and moving and
she kept like looking over at her mirror
like to see her work and she her
explanation the makeup artists
explanation was that when you're doing
makeup at least for her like she'll work
on this and she'll work on that like
she'll like jump around the face and not
really not until she's done is it like
does it all come together and so cardi
kept saying like I don't like what
you're doing like I don't like this or
she kept saying like I look like I'm not
dead yet I'm not a ghost or whatever
like she could say not see yourself the
first time I know looking like a [ __ ]
cadaver exactly the publicist comes in
and says like oh can you like contour
her a little bit or whatever and then
the makeup artist is like yeah I keep
reassuring her like don't worry I'm
gonna fix it's gonna turn out just the
way you liked it last time like don't
worry it'll be fine and she's like I'm
not gonna be doing what cardi and the
poses is wanting me to do because then
she's gonna come out looking like a
pumpkin because they wanted to keep
making her look darker yeah and then so
that's like her whole thing right and
then she ends up saying that it
escalates to a point where cardi gets so
heated at her that the makeup artist is
like like look I'm already telling you I
can fix this I don't know what else I
can do so I just asked her like do you
want me to leave and then car do you
think yeah get the [ __ ] out and so she
ended up leaving and I she's like start
she starts crying at this point in the
video and then she's like you know it's
just like I worked so hard and I tried
to do my best but then like she never
gave me a chance to fix a she never even
let me do my work to begin with because
she kept moving she kept doing all these
things and so she was just venting this
whole story out and then she she said
that she even called her a [ __ ] at one
point and so all that comes out that
goes by
and then card Ian's of commenting on it
and saying that like no this girl she
showed up an hour late highest [ __ ] she
brought people up to my room and like
you know you can't do your job properly
then I'm gonna tell you to get the [ __ ]
out like you just need to learn how to
do your job properly and that's what
cardi was saying on one of her Instagram
lives and then that's when the makeup
artist comes out and says like look I
have receipts like I showed up on time
they wanted me to be there at 3:00 I
showed up there 8 minutes early fax so
then the next thing to is she's like so
now I have people saying I do drugs
because of cardi B this is not okay I
don't care what people have to say about
my video the fact that I'm a mother
because she has two kids and she's
saying this is a whole new level drug
allegations are not taken lightly and so
she's saying like she has me completely
confused with somebody else like I don't
do drugs like I would never show up to a
client's house with people's latest on
people just from that picture of her
face she doesn't unless she doesn't do
drugs I think I'm gonna say yeah maybe
cardi does a little bit of drugs no she
got the first Lamborghini SUV in the
u.s. that's dope for all her drugs is it
dope looking that sounds so weird to
picture in my head for some reason
Lamborghini truck SUV picture that for a
second I'm like hmm whoa does that look
like
good luck say look next to this so when
she was doing that live Instagram live
when she was talking about this whole
thing as she was getting heated like she
was getting her makeup done by her
makeup artist and from what I saw and
during the video like it was funny
because like the makeup artist kept
trying to like come in with the lip
gloss and shoot and Accardi be like no
and then blend that in and then also
there's B what she said only reaffirms I
think she was talking about
like she just talks a lot and she moves
a lot while they're trying to do her
makeup which just confirms what the
other girl was saying I wonder if she
does that during surgery well your
surgery is what she does when she's
sleeping she I wonder if she does that
when she gets dental work but yeah so a
lot of people are obviously on cardi
side because well cuz she has those
party forever yeah of course like she
could do no wrong right so yeah and then
this other girl like she's just getting
a lot of heat but she has the [ __ ]
receipt
she says she showed up an hour late and
it's like boom she showed up like yeah
are you telling me that card II don't
know what I love public like public
court like how all this is well actually
the evidence here on her phone says that
she was there eight minutes early and
it's like wall according to cardi she
was an hour late and then like it's no
point looks like he says she said how do
you you look at exhibit a another thing
too is that cardi was saying that this
came that this whole thing happened two
years ago and it was before her boudic
yellow song came out but then the makeup
artist was like no this happened in
December of this last like you know a
year ago so then the video was like in
January yeah the video was posted in
January which was like a few weeks after
that whole thing happened because like
how do we know for example that she was
supposed to be there at 3:00
she could have s well she could have
been she supposed to be that too and she
got there 252 and she's like I'm parked
across the street again oh no because
she does have a screenshot of the call
sheets and say oh hey cardi wants you to
be here at 3:00 or whatever okay one is
proof cardi deserves to go to the court
of public opinion and then you're the
you're in it well I'm in it right now
cuz I have to be a part of the game is
still carry forever carny forever though
absolutely I just liked our video about
taxes because I was like that's
everything I always say sure we're my
[ __ ] buddy
I'll go say [ __ ] you buddy I want
receipts I want receipts where the
moment hug of money where the money I'll
go say I love not going to
Rhodes don't tell me it's going to the
right I don't think I know right you
know it's funny
obvious in in like our state California
highly Democrat right big city like LA
we're [ __ ] collecting a lot of tax
money where's the [ __ ] is wrong shitty
schools god Bless America some shitty
little town like in Texas or whatever it
the roads are [ __ ] brand new all the
time it's not how about this you drive
into Beverly Hills and you could fall
asleep the roads are so smooth but yeah
everywhere else everything's [ __ ]
yeah all the time dude sorry
you guys should come to South Pasadena
same thing they got a nice ass roads oh
yeah actually yeah yeah but kidding
they'll be stopped - Adina was like one
of those spots brought I saw them what's
it called on Monterey they were repaving
around I was like this is gonna take a
[ __ ] month took five days Wow
what the [ __ ] Cecina then me and Nikki
we're doing a podcast by Wilshire yeah
and the road they've been doing
construction there for like six years
yup yeah what the [ __ ] are they doing
it's a construction racket like they
[ __ ] yeah dude like Caltrans all
those [ __ ] they just chill and
just slowly build and trucking siphon
taxes right now dude those just wanted
to bring that up so what's with the they
closed down the whole [ __ ] 405 or
whatever yeah and and then I'm driving
it because the cones are like I'm
supposed to be one lane with everybody
we're all [ __ ] as hell hole all
completely [ __ ] nothing then I'm
driving through there's nothing anything
maybe a Caltrans truck parked with the
sirens on and it's just chilling you're
talking about the one where it's like
134 and
the other one it's like on the way to
Athena forever forever as long as I've
been in Hawaii I did stop saying this
one phrase though like after it actually
happened I was like dude there was so
much traffic all that do somebody better
be [ __ ] dead and then somebody was
and I was like I will not say that
phrase anymore Wow stretch I was like
I've seen it almost every time I go show
somebody be Harley
oh yeah I had the worst luck at that
[ __ ] I always see cars on fire I see
that - oh yeah
like just [ __ ] huge cars on fire you
know that's just so funny though when
when they're not dead but the cars on
fire they're just daddy good when I used
to work at the rail in hospital I saw I
was on my way to work and I saw this car
trying to get past a truck it's like the
lanes were merging and this car was like
oh I'll beat the truck into the lane and
the car smacks into the side of the
truck and it goes from like looking like
a pristine beautiful car
it's like looking like a war-torn
Somalian [ __ ] like still driving
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]